sit on
yes it's a little
different so here we we're here you feel
you okay so I'm going to move it
slightly
see you're over
here go back
over move this
SL go back don't push it way out there
lost my
CER I push it right after contact I push
it right at the edge of my center now I
go
up five feel Al okay I push it just at
the edge and then I follow this line
till it's too late for you to do
something I'm going to go inside this
angle
here and just push stay there please
stay where you
were this is this is where I want this
space you see then I'm on the center
l p over I see how my hands are still on
my
side and then I move checking try to go
back you think okay
here it's just a little more
Dynamic ever so
subtle
see it's not weak cuz you're going to
try to come back when you see and I
can't have
that try to come back
okay and I just got to get inside your
tip push inside the tip
and push me
over don't let me go back okay he's
coming
in yeld he coming in
pushing
over and move out of the way of the
weapon
[Music]
noce I'm holding this weapon so if he
has his sword he doesn't let go he can't
come back into me come into me checking
that that
elbow
around here is going to rotate so he has
his tip
coming you have to be around it
okay not going like this off to the
side that way you're sucking him in okay
you want him to
go like he's going to get it
don't let him feel your weapon don't
push back to the left don't lift
up around all way
try
it all right so couple things he goes
I'm going to be as light as possible
to as possible okay then I need a good
things and I need an anchored
elbow if I'm short
this will work sternum will work face
will work okay let the anchored elbow de
side let's say you're short no elbow not
anchored anchored elbow good
base you're hitting more with that
elbow the elbow's
hitting
elbow elbow
not a
light you have to put your whole body
into there okay so for
example you don't have to grab be a
pushing that would represent like his
mouth you see okay and so push that way
you see
okay and I'm hitting with that give a
good B put your bracing angle in there
in
there
push not going anywhere
boom that's what you're hitting him
with oh that's hitting okay
look like you have some cker
[Music]
so on this side he pushes my sword this
way and I'm going to come
under like
this it and I'm on the
other don't forget your target is the
throat so his SW to go up right you
understand
no here he
go on
[Music]
right when he's pushing you that's what
you use that energy to come around
boom
okay he moves your SW he moves come on a
little
[Music]
more don't
need pull into theque pull him into
theque now go forward and back okay
do the first
move come on come
on come
on look where I end up
[Music]
okay so same thing
push
push push on the
tip you can grab it with your hand
get a good base not really killing it
just everything's
align
okay in your Parry go slow when I come
around I'm shielding it
don't come around
like you want this angled
into okay
I'm I'm just going to follow that space
I'll show you where it
is
right and not here right
you see that I to turn the
weapon this
way okay then I have my shaving angle
see it and you're going to try to come
this way right you're going to try to
hit me that I'm sliding down at this I'm
inside the
sh again I'll show it boom he goes
around and I go this way
without doing anything
if your sword turn boy you go around
[Music]
it I'm going yeah I have to keep my
hands low
I don't want to come up
here my hands
stay see how my hands are checking come
back at me you
see I'm not pushing him but he can't
come back at me
[Music]
thank TR